ah good morning Millennials welcome back
to the morning toast
I just told Claudia that Joe Rogan sold
to Spotify for over a hundred million
dollars according to The Wall Street
Journal and she is shook so hey Claude
how you durn I'm shook cause you and I
we're gonna talk about it but you and I
were talking about it like privately
yesterday just wondering how much I had
heard that there's like a certain
formula that Spotify abides by when it
comes to like buying podcast and we
thought it was like at least 20 million
but a hundred oh my god I cannot wait to
dive into that hi everyone
happy Wednesday it's dirty make sure to
have someone you love today even if it's
your dog because that's what I'm gonna
be doing right after this speaking of
where is the thought the botch is
spending some time with his father
um which is okay hate to see it but deep
deep deep down you know in the basement
of my soul I do know that Theo likes Ben
better so that's just like my cross to
bear in this lifetime I don't think
that's true but that's very generous of
you to say well it's also very generous
of bed to walk Theo four out of four
times a day I do it maybe like once or
twice a week so it's no wonder why CEO
likes Ben better so it's okay
that's very true well happy Wednesday
everyone just almost got ahead of myself
um it's another beautiful day here in
New York City very very exciting I
actually have such a full day today I'm
like stressed but not my usual anxiety
stress just like work stressed ya know
it's a nice change I too have a busy day
I'm thinking I'm going to head over to
get an antibody test um from City MD so
I think I'm gonna do that I have a lot
of work to do we are interviewing Lauren
gray a little later today she'll be on
tomorrow's episode so yes me too you it
feels good to have but you know a
planner chock-full of events chock-full
of events we're recording the redheads
today clog this book that I chose for
the redheads it's just like split the
group into because for controversial I
was talking to the snitch and I was
about to cancel two books a month I was
like we can't handle it I can't choose
another book like blah blah blah and
then I spoke to Dana and Dana was like
this is the best book we've read so far
it's so literary like it's just on
another level and I need to stop
listening to everyone else and just like
did I like the book or not
but it really was so literary and I look
forward Dana really like explains things
to us like a teacher so I'm actually
really excited to record the redheads
and find out what I what was it that I
just read can I ask you a logistics
question about your quarantine like when
you're busy are you still using your
planner oh that's such a great question
for two months I did not touch my
planner but actually in the lead up to
this week I was wondering when I was
gonna get my period so I put it in my
planner the last times I got my period
so I could like start counting the days
and trying to figure it out so while I
was in there I added some things you
know um the only things I added were the
live method virtual training sessions
that I'm doing because I do like to know
how many times I do it and now I think
I'm gonna start getting back to it
because not adding like you know Lauren
actually maybe I will Adler and Lauren
grace or even floor but we add our
interviews to our planners but I feel
like weirdly I just have things going on
now and they need to be planned that's
the thing about plans you got to plant
them and that's the thing about like the
slow reopening like I do feel as though
my life is slowly very slowly like 1%
getting open yeah I actually my life
feels exactly the same but I feel like
I'm seeing people influencers
celebrities in New York and LA like
doing more things without crazy backlash
which makes me think that like we're
starting to reopen I think yeah and if
they get backlash like they just don't
like everyone is doing what's best for
themselves and I think that that should
be applied to everyone everywhere
whether you're an influencer or not just
if you think what you're doing is safe
and you know that you're taking the
right precautions and you know the
people that you're wearing you know that
they've been wearing masks and
Quarantine do what you gotta do stay
saying everyone yeah um but my life is
you know still the same it's been for
the last three months but like I said
I'm having you know overly coaster of
emotions and today I'm feeling like you
know I don't mind quarantine I could go
a few more months yeah no not a few more
months but I am feeling today like okay
just another day in the queue in a
positive way like dice now it doesn't
feel like kimmy schmitt and we're like
the mold women it feels like we're just
like
life and this is what life is now yeah I
I would agree it helps on a busy day but
yeah so it's not busy days man mad sad
and so we all have a bunch of good stuff
to talk about we're gonna do tear
toasters which is our advice segment and
we are also going to recap the new
episode of Ben or pump rules which was
the season finale last night that was an
hour and fifteen minutes which was weird
and I can tell ya and I'm excited to
talk about it okay cool I'm excited
should we actually have some great
stories I think we're gonna have some
interesting discussions today and I
think maybe just like without further
ado et's time yeah I also we'll all
caught up officially on all the seasons
of drag race so with the reunion this
week in the finale next week I can give
my thoughts but I want to wrap up where
I'm at and I'll do that in our TV recap
segment great love it oh and I finished
money heist turns out I only had like 20
minutes of the last episode like I
always do that like where I break it up
and then I have to get back into it and
it's over Barry and Ben plots Netflix
special came out today which we have to
watch oh and I did not watch song land
even though you only gave me 24 hours so
I will mute myself when you want to talk
about it okay maybe maybe you'll get
lucky and I'll forget okay so eat it's
time for the Fast Five story is that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true joke we but if I may
allow me the floor for a mere 60-second
ad brought to you by liquid IV liquid IV
is an easy healthy solution for
dehydration one stick of liquid I be in
16 ounces of water hydrates you faster
and more efficiently than water alone
each serving provides as much hydration
as two to three bottles of water plus
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12 so if you're
dehydrated charlyk would I be it's the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated proper hydration is crucial for
your immune system and can boost your
immunity they have more vitamin C than
an orange and potassium more than more
potassium than a banana it's packed with
vitamins b3 b5 b6 and b12 which your
vitamins known to help your body defend
against infections and dehydration
occurs daily and 3 out of 4 people which
can lead to headaches I can attest it up
dizziness brain fog muscle fatigue
muscle cramps dry skin and more
so to stay hydrated with water alone
you'd have to drink eight full eight
ounces glass eight ounces of water a day
which is so hard even when you're not
busy like I could just knock it myself
drink water it's like so time-consuming
and exhausting but liquid ideal adds
little flavor makes it a lot easier if
you're hungover it's a fabulous um
regimen yeah yeah I think so one serving
of liquid IV it provides the same
hydration as drinking two to three
bottles of water alone and it contains
two five essential vitamins that you
need and it's super effective because of
its cellular transport technology the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water and nutrients
directly into the bloodstream so if you
want to get liquid IV it's available
nationwide at Target Whole Foods and
Costco but if you want to get 25% off
you can go to liquid IV calm and use the
code toast at checkout that's 25% off
anything you order when you use promo
code toast at liquid I be calm get
better hydration today at liquid IV com
from a co toast you can also find the
nationwide at Target Whole Foods and
Costco sign-on get hydrated let's jump
right in I'm ready to dive on the deep
in okay first story the big story of the
day especially in the podcast world
actually there's two big stories of the
day in the podcast world so and you know
and they're - they're the two biggest
podcasts in the podcast world but it's
just so different how they're being
treated
Spotify strikes a podcast deal with Joe
Rogan worth more than 100 million
dollars according to The Wall Street
Journal his full library dating back 11
years is to hit the service on September
1st and become exclusive to Spotify
after that before the end of the year
Wow damn okay you know this is just like
so exciting obviously I'm so happy for
Joe Rogan that I got 100 million dollars
but I feel like it's such a huge step
for podcasters everywhere I cannot
believe that the figure was 100 million
dollars but like literally he's one of
the most influential people in the world
like when he endorsed Bernie Sanders it
was like such a big deal like he's
really really influential in so many
different circles I don't even know what
his numbers are but he must be getting
millions of downloads per episode which
very few podcasts get I'm very happy for
him he seems like a hard-working guy and
this is fabulous like this is just so
exciting I
it's gonna take a bit of an adjustment
for the audience who might have always
been listening to him on YouTube or on
iTunes but Spotify is a free platform um
there's no reason why this should really
affect his numbers but it'll be
interesting to see if it does yeah this
is a major move for Spotify in the
podcasting world to just go and chomp
down on the biggest podcast they just
[ __ ] snatchler that this really
reminds me of Howard Stern and when he
went to serious and not really like took
his whole audience with him and Sirius
became like this big like bigger than
radio so I think this is just an
interesting tidbit for the podcasting
world I'm so happy for him you know he's
a hard-working man I totally agree and I
just think this is interesting all
around and I'm and I'm very happy and I
also love Spotify as a platform and if
Spotify is the next big thing in
podcasting that really works for me and
my routine no it works for me as a
person but it also works for me as a
podcast hoes obviously like I have many
interests here I have a lot of sticks in
this fire um and I agree to Spotify like
for music for me it's like the end-all
be-all like I can't I don't even
understand how people like pay for
Pandora or Apple music like it's they're
just such subpar platforms in comparison
to Spotify so it makes sense that they
should become like an all-around audio
platform whether that's music or
podcasts they've started to integrate
like videos on a lot of their podcasts
like some of the guys from the vlog
squad have a podcast and they now get
their video on Spotify which is like
sickening for a couple video podcasters
right Joe Rogan does video on YouTube
and now all of that will be on Spotify
which is major and I'm glad that like
Spotify is prioritizing podcasts as well
which is yeah what we do and then that's
why that figure 100 million makes a lot
of sense because he's now losing all of
his YouTube ad revenue which I'm sure
was a lot of money not a hundred million
but it's all just like contributes when
you go exclusive on Spotify like you
lose other revenue streams so but you
have two million 100 million dollars so
I think I take my YouTube stream I'll
take one hundred million dollars in five
[ __ ] seconds which I think it
balances itself out yeah but this is
just fascinating big news for podcasters
congratulations to everyone involved
I'm so happy and jealous yes I totally
agree now switching gears and I think
this will provide a lot of context into
our next story which is still the
biggest story of the week they call her
daddy saga continues Jackie I am so
invested in this I had a dream about it
okay Wow
I like got cancelled for saying
something about it because I feel like
I'm actually on an unpopular side of the
whole debacle I agree I feel like so am
i and they want oh my god I'm getting
choked up I'm getting emotional I'm so
I'm so invested in this because like do
you know what it's reminding me of a
little bit the James Charles Tati
Westbrook thing when Tati released her
video that was facts she wasn't saying
anything untrue just like Dave but
without James's context perspective and
just emotions that went behind decisions
everyone railed into James then a week
later we're reeling into Tati and I
don't know if we're ever gonna get that
video from Sophia definitely not from
soup man of what was going on on their
side but I just feel like this is so
one-sided right now I think soup man is
such a convenient villain for the whole
story and while it's funny and stuff
it's funny to like ruin people's lives
and make fun of them on the internet all
day um I do think that there is more to
the story and I kind of I want to get
into all of it right and part of the
reason why I'm now taking I think I'm
really more taking the side of Sophia is
because I feel like the way that they're
going after a private citizen a man with
a job who is just like trying to do
right by his girlfriend like I feel like
that's really unfair and now I'm just
feeling like I want to fight for what I
perceive to be the underdog which is
Superman and if you don't know what
we're talking about
we recapped this story the first half of
it on Monday's episode so check that out
but this is the the second coming of the
collar daddy drama yes so in the past
few days you know it's become a meme
it's everywhere everyone is kind of like
railing on Sophia especially Superman so
yesterday Sophia took to Instagram
stories to speak her mind she didn't say
very much except the interesting factoid
was that she feels that Alex her co-host
stabbed her in the back so that's really
all we got from Matt then day twice
twice yet
Dave did an emergency press conference
sort of addressing what Sophia had said
and really still no new information but
it's always entertaining to get a video
from Dave spilling the tea guzzling it
and spitting it out and I feel torn
because like I actually really like El
Presidente like I think he's so funny
and really smart and I love how he like
combats the haters in the media like I
totally am with him on that um I just
feel like it's gone so far to the point
where it's like really not nice and I
know that's like so lame of me to say
like doesn't care but like I'm just like
feeling for suit man right now and I
don't like it was bad at all okay I
totally agree and I understand that this
is what Barstow does and clear owes
people they have the thickest skin they
do it to each other and that's the
community but like from what I'm seeing
on the internet it's just become we all
say like [ __ ] cancel Co choke but that's
literally what we're doing right now
like Sophia in the last three days has
lost her job probably um her friendship
and now like how can her relationship
survive this I don't understand so I
just want to offer like an alternate
perspective of what I think happened in
the months leading up to this brouhaha I
don't know that this happened but I'm
just putting myself in someone else's
shoes also being in the podcasting
industry recognizing that call her daddy
and Joe Rogan are one and two in the
podcast or Joe Rogan just signed a 100
million dollar deal and these girls are
being called greedy for not taking half
a million dollars for a year okay Lee
and I think we all need to acknowledge
how differently we speak about call her
daddy just because they are women like
it is so glaringly obvious like how this
conversation is so misogynistic like
I've been seeing tik toks
everywhere that like Alex and Sophia
were pretending to be relatable but they
were really making five hundred thousand
dollars a year and five hundred thousand
dollars a year is a lot of money but if
you know you're worth in the podcast
industry for a show that big that I want
to assume has about two million
downloads per episode $500,000 is
nothing yeah it's nothing so okay I've
been following them for a while I think
Sophia and Su man have been dating for
over a year because I remember she went
to the Game of Thrones premiere because
he works at HBO and so they that was
over a year ago so I'm gonna say they've
been together for over a year
her boyfriend works in media he's the VP
of HBO Sports so he understand
like the value of a podcast I know HBO
is into podcasting now he sees that his
girlfriend hosts and her friend hosted
number one podcast in the country in the
world sometimes and then she's making a
base salary at the time of $70,000 now
that is a [ __ ] joke I understand that
they signed a contract but they are
employees of Barse well and they deserve
raises over time especially based on
performance weight also I think what you
just said is so important because a lot
of the rhetoric being said it's like
they can't just break their contract and
I understand how it looks that way where
it's like they have a show and they have
to do it a certain amount of time but at
the end of the day they're just
employees so they really it wasn't
necessarily breaking a contract they
could have just like quit like it's not
it's not like you're a talent I just
don't think that the deal was structured
that way where it's like we are talent
and we will do a show for X amount of
time it's like their employees they can
leave whenever they want right so they
were gonna quit and go to wonder ii and
so this is where it gets interesting so
he's watching her be underpaid for a
very long time her and her friend I
think if I don't know this I'm just
speculating I'm just plating a story in
my head he was like you guys are
underpaid let me show you what your
podcast is worth went out got them a
deal I'm gonna say the deal did where
the numbers ever confirmed on the deal
no I think it the deal what did that Lea
spin a million and a half dollars each
for both of them yeah like nothing just
to show them like that is what they're
worth
not even shading that deal just like the
initial offer was at least three million
dollars it had to have been because I
know what our network gives other people
like it's just it's I would actually say
it might have been more ya know but I'm
just I'm just trying to be conservative
here just so that they can see how
underpaid they are and I understand
barstool is a major marketing machine
they have so much to do with the success
of call her daddy but at the end of the
day bar swill has a lot of other
podcasts a few other female hosted
podcasts that are not call her daddy so
there is something about these two girls
and they had value and I know you think
they only work two hours of the week but
what they do in those two hours is worth
more than half a million dollars a year
it just is according to the facts
according to Spotify according to The
Wall Street Journal to the industry
industry standard so I think this was a
guy who thought who saw his girlfriend
and her friend are getting underpaid
he wants to just show them what they're
worth in order maybe to give them the
confidence to go and renegotiate ro they
realize with a deal at wonder e they'd
have to start their show over very
similar to the breath and the toast so
like we've been in a sedition
but mark they can't get their Instagram
call her daddy which has over a million
followers and that's tough I get that
like when we had to leave the morning
breath like we were only a hundred
thousand followers we were devastated we
did everything we could to get the
trademark like we were meeting with the
lawyer it's like we did everything we
could and then it dawned on us we had no
choice like we couldn't get it so like
the decision was made for us so I
understand why it's difficult for them
to like not see beyond like a year from
now where it doesn't really matter like
you can get an Instagram back you can
get your viewership back you like a
podcast isn't really in the name if you
have an audience right so they start
going down or entertaining this one Dury
path where they'd have to start the show
over they lose the IP lose the Instagram
handles it would be called the father's
but they would own it they would be
getting paid much more and in a year
from now the show if it if it really is
them that's the success of the show the
show will be is no one will remember
color daddy they're just the father's
now and they will have spent the last
year making real money and building
something of their own so once you go
from like having the mentality of oh wow
like this could be ours we could be
making millions a year base salary
without merge without touring without
any of that I understand the half a
million dollars a year with just salary
they could have been making more on top
of that but all of that is based all
those bonuses are based on how well you
do your job you know but they deserve
more just bottom line yeah so I unlike
even though to us when Dave says he
offered them half a million dollars
fifty-fifty on the roof you get your
show in a year when you're already going
down the path of I'm gonna own my show
we're gonna start over we're gonna start
it from scratch and we're gonna build it
up and in a year we'll have made our
money back and own our show and we
didn't spend the last year like you know
having to go back to barstool tail
between our legs
it's it's hard to do that I understand
that Alex made that choice and Sophia
didn't and now we're in this place and
it's really sad on and now that if Alex
wanted to accept that deal which like
I'm just putting myself in my position
like
I would have probably entertained the
Wonder ideal um but if Alex obviously
likes being at barstool there's
definitely many benefits to being a part
of the barstool family and I totally got
that I just need to know if she went
behind Sophia's back and took the deal
or if she told Sophia like we can't
agree but I'm going you know there's a
difference yeah yeah there's a
difference because I haven't wanted Idol
to choose what they want to choose and
if they're not seeing eye-to-eye that
sucks
but if Alex went behind her back like
that definitely constitutes as a
betrayal yeah because regardless if they
both went to bar stool and they took
that deal or they both went to rendering
and they took that deal like they will
be fine but when they when there's a
free bar between them like now it's
become sad the show isn't what it was
I'm sure if Alex doesn't show with bar
stool I'm sure she'll get a different
co-host but it's gonna be a co-worker
and it's forcing I always wonder do
these people even like each other where
it's like her and Sophia were just like
your best friend goals and you don't
come around that often they were their
most powerful when they were on the same
page or at least willing to make a
decision together and the minute that
one of them made a choice without the
other is where they lost all their power
especially Sophia yeah no I totally
agree and now I just feel badly for
Sophia I don't I just I feel bad we say
that we're not gonna do this to people
you know like that were anti cancel
culture but like look what's going on it
just makes me so sad and at the end of
the day they are worth so like everyone
without perspective like sees half a
million dollars and it's just like oh my
god how could they not take it they're
so greedy but Joe Rogan who they guess
has 11 years under his belt but whose
numbers are similar on there's a hundred
million dollars I totally agree these
stories couldn't have come out at a
better time and I agree I feel like
we're who I feel the most bad for is
soup man like first of all I agree it's
an easy villain like let's just blame it
on soup man for sure and I get that it's
funny but at the end of the day this is
a private citizen who's not a public
figure who doesn't have social media and
really shouldn't be dragged it's really
um [ __ ] up and I want to say it's
borderline illegal
house like - he's up he's not a public
figure like he's not protected in that
in that what he should be protected in
that way yeah for barstool it's like you
came for us we're coming for you don't
start with us because you don't want to
finish with us but I just think like for
the means and the tick tocks like it's
and even in just the toaster groups is
really what we're I sort of get the
pulse of what people are saying and the
toasters are very and sometimes it's
like sympathetic Bunch and we all agree
like we're anti cancel culture so like
what are we doing ruining those people's
lives at the end of the day he might
have just been trying to help his
girlfriend get paid for the work that
she does he's girlfriend and her friend
and her friend yeah no I I see soup man
I know this is so controversial I see
him as the hero of this story I do I do
and I feel so bad for a minute I'm sure
like honestly like him and Sophia like
want to kill each other right now
they're quarantine and he's like I'm a
businessman bow I am a shoe man and now
I'm being dragged on Twitter and on to
talk like I'm on reddit like I feel for
soup man justice for a soup man and I
know that's like a not popular opinion
at all but I'm just feeling like why is
this private citizen who was just trying
to help his girlfriend and her roommate
like no they're worth empower women like
how is he the villain no I totally
completely agree but it's all about
perspective and how you see things and I
just I don't see Sophia making this
video people are saying she's not saying
much because she's getting ready to sue
I don't think there needs to be lawsuits
like Sophia now's our friends I think I
don't know if it might be too far gone
for them to come back together but I
think just at least the world needs to
just let up on them like how much can
one person take unless I know worried
about their mental health like hey Jesus
this happens all the time
and like people just don't care no I
completely agree I think it's pretty
safe to say call her daddy is not coming
back in the way that it once was I think
Alex will get her own show at bars too
like Dave said on his press conference
he's like so you can come back I'll give
her her own show but I don't think after
what they've done to like her and her
boyfriend she could ever return no I
don't think so either
also Dave put out a video this morning
on the call her daddy page saying it
you wanna host a podcast cuz a lot of
people are now tea I mean like I'll do
with Alex I could do it one-hour talk
about my sex life make a half a million
dollars but he's like no for real like
if you want to show a barstool send us
your audition tape to auditions at
Bart's TOCOM and they're not to replace
caller daddy he's like we're gonna work
it out with the caller daddy girls but
if you want your own show we're always
looking for new talent so I actually
think that's a really positive way to
get a you know a better outcome out of
all of this and it's like I don't think
there's a villain in this story I like
and respect Dave I like and respect Alex
and Sophia and I don't know suit man but
I'm just he's not I'm not gonna let him
be this like Disney villain that is just
so easy or drugs I think right for us to
think of him as you know yes I agree I
don't think anyone here is lying I think
this is the definition of like there's
three sides to every story and it's like
everyone is telling their version of the
truth I don't think anyone's lying or
being shady and I agree like but first
of all this is [ __ ] amazing press for
barstools like a podcast network like it
was really brilliant up Dave to like use
it as an opportunity like garner a new
talent and I and I don't think anyone
here is really in the wrong I just think
that like the way we're all reacting to
this it's like at the end of the day
it's like a [ __ ] podcast like chill
the [ __ ] out like it's so dramatic and
it's like so life or death and it's like
these are people my god it's like we
[ __ ] forget that all the time these
are people they have sisters and their
parents like [ __ ] off like chill the
[ __ ] out
yeah I totally completely agree but I'm
living for the drama I know I just hope
that it has a happy ending
you know I think that I think that Alex
will get her own show at barstool and if
there's a co-host it'll be like an
employee they will not be equal partners
and I think that Sophia will like
influence maybe start like a small
podcast with another network but just
like live the life I think she's like
seen she's seen a lot of the perks of
Fame and now she's living through like
the ugly stage and the highs are [ __ ]
high and the lows are even lower than
you can even imagine and I feel like she
might react to it in the sense like I'm
happy with my 800,000 Instagram
followers like I can make a living I
don't need to be the biggest podcaster
in the world because honestly like
sometimes it's just not worth it and
alex has really only seen the positive
side now everyone took her side she's
cool with bar stool they're defending
her all the memes all the tic TOCs are
like go Alex
so she hasn't really experienced what
kind of toll flipside of Fame can take
on your mental health so I think she'll
continue to like be podcaster number one
barceló caller data a podcast door
because right now she maybe doesn't know
what the alternative is but sophia has
seen the alternative and I feel like she
might be done yeah the only way for this
to work now at this point for them to
get back together and Sophia said this
in her video like she's not gonna be 25%
well Alex is 75 she said I'm not gonna
be her employee
um so Alex would need to give up that
extra 25 that she earned in coming
forward and they would be 50/50 which is
why it needs to still be a conversation
like just between the girls like
forgetting each other but I don't know
if that's gonna happen at this point and
I've kind of given up hope for it I just
hope that everyone like makes it out
okay because now I'm just like starting
to get worried about people no I totally
agree and I don't know if I was out if I
were Alex like but I just got a [ __ ]
amazing deal but I give up 25% but a
show like that where it's two co-hosts I
understand that the narrative is being
said that like Alex does more what works
and then Sophia and that might be the
case play talk about it let's split up
the responsibilities 5050 like we're 50
I like there are ways to mend that but I
can't imagine like being to co-host of a
podcast with they at one has 800,000
followers one is a million followers
like they're both bringing something to
the table I just can't imagine it not
being 50/50 and that's where podcast
deals or deals into any kind like a
boyband like that's where she gets messy
yeah I totally agree so that's that on
that
that's that on that wow I look forward
to seeing how the story develops and I
hope that maybe you guys will just be a
little kinder to Sophia and seumas yeah
justice pursue ma'am justice for Sophia
okay next story really shocking turn
Kristin Cavallari decides not to
continue with very Cavallari amid her
divorce from Jay Cutler so Kristin
Cavallari posted like a glam photo in
front of a green screen to her Instagram
yesterday I thought it was gonna be like
we're filming I was like wow in the
quarantine how and instead she said that
during this new chapter in her life she
will not be continuing on with very
capillary which I'm assuming means the
show is completely over because she is
very Cavallari and I guess it makes
sense because like they focused a lot on
Kristin and Jay and she doesn't focus on
her kids
take out her home life completely and
it's just like Cavallari rules but
people don't even like her employees and
there's just I think she just got out
before she was before the show went
downhill and I actually really respect
that yeah I read a theory on Twitter
that I totally believe which is
essentially that she's going into
divorce proceedings with Jay who has
like made you know 150 million dollars
last year or whatever um and I'm sure
that Barry Cavallari was probably her
number one stream of income and like in
a court of law I think she's just
positioning herself it better now to
take what's rightfully hers which is
potentially house Oh interesting cuz if
she has this big income coming in every
year how can they say that she needs his
money right and if they're splitting
custody like she it's it's on the court
and her husband to make sure that like
she is able to sufficiently provide for
her family and if she doesn't have the
show then I think the next thing would
be like okay well let me take from the
marital funds understood I don't know
interesting theory yeah I don't know if
that's how divorce works but the the
thread made a compelling case I kind of
I see that or I feel like maybe that was
just like one reason but you know like
it just subcontracting this show the
show like I'm gonna into her friendship
with that girl Kelly like you know it
put a spotlight on her marriage and I
think ultimately you know now it's like
this income that she would have to share
with the courts and I think ultimately
it's doing more harm than good yeah but
at the end of the day I've literally
never in my life felt compelled to turn
on Barry Cavallari now I'm like maybe I
would watch it like she's kind of just
getting interesting yeah maybe she'll go
back to the hills oh yeah Scrabble I
love a good tail between her legs Mole
Man I wonder if she'll stay in Nashville
I think she'll have to you like for the
kids in Jay but if you watch the show
she really didn't have much aside from
her store like she didn't have many
friends and she was always missing
Chicago and I feel like without Jay
what's keeping her there no no no I
don't know okay next up a really sweet
story from one of our favorite people
here at the toe yeah yes
yes see a confirm she adopted two
teenage sons who were aging out of the
foster care system quote I love them
SIA is opening up about her life as a
mom the singer confirmed that she
welcomed two sons into her family last
year during an interview with Sirius
XM's the morning mashup on Tuesday
sharing that she adopted the teenage
boys when they were leading foster care
due to their age quote I actually
adopted two sons last year they were
both 18 they're both 19 years old now
they were aging out of the foster care
system yeah and I love them oh my god I
think this is the sweetest story I love
SIA so much I'm like so happy for her
and her growing family and I just we
have no choice but to Stan know every
time I hear something about C it makes
me a bigger fan than ever and this is
just such a beautiful like sentiment
like kids aren't the only ones who need
parents like everyone needs a family no
matter what age you're at so I love this
and you know they always say like was
that movie Oh like Mike Weir it's like
older kids in the foster care system are
much it's much less likely that they'll
ever get adopted when people come in
looking for like to adopt they want like
a newborn like the cutest one and so
it's harder as you grow older so I just
feel like this is such a beautiful
statement such a beautiful message I
[ __ ] love SIA everything she does is
special and wonderful and I'm so happy
for these kids because like SIA as your
mom everything of the sort no totally
and you know her relationship with the
Kardashians was really just icing on the
cake and how much I stand her and I just
I love when like my people in my corner
it's just like she was right there so
worthy of my shift um yeah like I feel
good I lay my head on my pillow at night
I'm like I support SIA and that's a good
thing
yeah yeah okay fit in vinyl storage is a
weird one a weird historical artifacts
story historical artifacts story I love
a historical artifact story okay a judge
has ordered that the salvage firm can
recover the Titanic's Telegraph machine
a federal judge in Virginia has ruled
that a salvage firm can retrieve the
Marconi wireless Telegraph machine that
broadcast distress calls from the
sinking Titanic ocean liner in an order
released on Monday US District Judge
rebecca beach Smith agreed that
Telegraph is historically and culturally
important and could soon be lost within
the rapidly decaying wreck site so
they're gonna go back down to the
Titanic to get this Telegraph machine
there are people who are like up in arms
about it because it's a grave site for
the 1500 people who died just so you got
a telegraph machine which is interesting
but um I don't know we'd have a question
this might be like the dumbest question
ever you're gonna say but if there's
like a like a shipwreck and people die
do they like take them out and bury them
or they leave them down there oh that's
not what I thought you were gonna say at
all I believe that they would leave them
down there like if it's some well no
because sometimes the bodies wash up
well I guess it's like if if nobody
knows where the ship like the ship goes
missing of course years later maybe they
find the boat but they're they can't
find the boat at first so they're not
gonna bury the people but it's like when
the Titanic sank did like everyone knew
yeah like the police and everyone showed
up at the end of the Titanic like did
they take the people out of the water
and give them proper funerals or did
they just like leave them down there to
die I think if they were like floating
on the water they probably took them out
like the ones that went down that went
down with the ship
I think they might still be in the ship
I would definitely understand some of
the frustration of like people going
down to get a Telegraph but like not
their loved ones I actually would agree
with some of the backlash that that's
incredibly [ __ ] weird I thought you
were gonna ask if the necklace from the
movie was a real thing like maybe
they're going down there for some buried
treasures just like OBX
can I say something so controversial
please I think that the movie the
Titanic like sucks oh my god it's having
controversial it's just wrong oh I think
it's just right no like that movie is so
so good no like these kids are just so
dramatic like oh but your parents room
like the whole thing was bothering me
what I will say though is that Kate
Winslet was completely miscast sorry was
like like she just was giving me like 40
year old vibes and Leos like 18
and I just thought they were a mismatch
um like where it's like leo was Jack
like he he was the perfect casting but I
just think that she was like not the
right Catholic the movie ultimately is
really good but she was just like a
little too like matronly yeah I just
didn't want to like be mean no I mean
like even at a young age she had a very
mature face and like they're supposed to
be kids but what I think of Kate Winslet
like in my mind she's always like I'm 35
40 years old a matron yeah a matron so I
actually I feel that call but I don't
think that's the way that's not why I
think the movies terrible like I just
like hate the whole thing like it's so
long when is the last time that you
watch it from start to finish like the
first time okay then that's why what
okay so we watched it as kids and like
obviously be it's like break it up
because it was like two different videos
and we could Jenny yeah we couldn't
watch any of the nude scenes and so I
was like what we were even doing
watching it but when we were in the
Bahamas a few years ago and I got
alcohol poisoning and I was subjected to
my bed for like two days straight and
you guys were like going out as you
should like they're wearing up not like
coming it's like you're still mad about
it no I'm not because on vh1 they were
playing Titanic and all I had was time
so I was like I'm gonna watch it and I
was just like so moved by it because you
know I love a true story the Titanic is
such an interesting historical story and
then they put this like not real love
story on top of it layered with like
real people like the Unsinkable Molly
Brown I think her name was who played
Kathy Bates and there was just like it
was so beautifully done they like
rebuilt the ship it's just an amazing
movie yawn I'm just like I'm not
interested I hate period pieces like I
hate old movies like anything that's not
in 2020 like it the [ __ ] out of my face
so yeah you know what you're entitled to
your opinion um you're entitled to your
opinion it's just like grandma central
like maybe I'm like when I'm a grandma
yeah I mean I I definitely became a
grandma at a young age yes that's why I
love it so much but yeah you have some
time so back to the story I'm glad
they're going down to get the Telegraph
but not the remains of human beings I
think that's just really special and
important you just don't get like why
this Telegraph machine like that yes
it's
if it floated up to the top and be like
yeah let's put it in a museum but like
there's so many other things on the ship
that are probably also culturally
important where this is also maybe a
dumb question where's the boat it's in
it's in the Atlantic between where it
was going from the UK or Ireland from
the UK I think to America
yeah to America so it would be the
Atlantic yeah it would be the Atlantic
interesting well cool I can't wait for
people to tweet at us like how much
misinformation we've been spread in the
story so Technic here the Titanic had
been traveling from England I was not
wrong to New York what I said here they
were coming down here to my bedroom when
it struck an iceberg and sank in 1912
killing all but seven hundred of the two
thousand two hundred and eight
passengers and crew killing seven
hundred killing all but seven hundred so
seventy seven hundred people survived
two thousand two hundred and eight -
seven hundred people yeah that's a weird
way to phrase it like why don't they
just say how many died like making us do
mathematician fifteen hundred people
automatics okay there's another
interesting paragraph that might like
clear some things up the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
which represents the public's the
public's interest in the wreck site
fiercely opposes the mission the NOAA
argued in court documents that the
Telegraph is likely surrounded quote by
the mortal remains of more than 1,500
people and shouldn't be left alone
agreed and it's like the rate remains or
so down there like why can't we get them
cuz they're like do I think
brittle no or like don't body's like
they just what's the word disintegrate
yeah flesh and bones are like fish eat
them yeah yeah but they could still you
know the soul that's hurting this I'm
speaking out I'm because I speak now
describe are you part of the NOAA now
I'm part of the oceanic vibe yeah the
brief transmissions sent among those
ships wireless operators ceccato bursts
of information and emotion tell the
story of Titanic
desperate faith that night the confusion
chaos panic futility and fear that's so
great let's pick up a box full of
recordings of people fearing for their
lives who the [ __ ] wants that yeah
no I'm I'm with the NOAA on this one
it's gonna be you know for me dog so
those are the five stories and honestly
I do feel as though you needed to know
them for sure very informative I hope
you get invited to a dinner party soon
if your state is allowing that
yeah maybe a zoom dinner party and let
us know what you think about them going
down to the Titanic for some you know
yesterday we asked a lot of the viewers
to let us know if they were also synched
up with us on their cycles um the third
period of the quarantine and a lot of us
twisters are synced up and I just think
that's wonderful and special and real
true bond of sisterhood
I completely agree um okay let's dive
into our TV recap segment let's talk
about Vanderpump rules season finale um
there were actually some wonderful parts
of it and it really for me cemented the
fact that like we need new blood like
the Danika Sheena double moment was
everything because you want to know why
neither of them have anything to lose
like they don't care they just want to
be make a scene like all of these oh
jeez like they have multimillion-dollar
mansions like they're not gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and be nuts they don't need to
do that anymore but Danica lives in a
tiny apartment I'm sure like she has
absolutely nothing to lose
sheena number two would like flew here
from vegas just to get her moment and
she was everything of the sort like i
wish they'd let her sit behind Stasi for
two more hours because I was dying and I
was loving it and Danica just like
putting her ass where it doesn't belong
but it started this amazing fight like
that was that was the best part of the
whole season I totally agree and this
one episode really cemented the need for
two different shows because there were a
few interesting moments and they took
place on completely different
hemispheres one Danika sheena 2.0 just
like the fact that there is a sheena 2.0
and like sheena loves her and i didnt
she's like you're like you look hot like
I just it's hilarious and that is like
what we need from the Sur crew then also
interesting one Stassi looking at houses
two million dollars
Botox saying that he's not going to put
down the down payment like thank you for
your honesty and Lala
trying to make a home with Randall
putting out some cheese's in macaroons
and in Bel Air nonetheless right in Bel
Air all the girls like sitting around
you
looking just on a different it's just a
different show there on a different show
and I would watch both of those shows
separately together it's just like I
can't I need to be in the zone for a
certain thing and um that's just I think
where this means to head next also they
didn't give us a preview for the reunion
I was really bummed because I've heard
the reunions really good they say that
about every union but it's also virtual
so like it can't be the best thing ever
but I'm sure it'll be good Atlanta one
was good um but we need to talk about
Jax we need to talk about Jax because
I'm a Jack's apologist but of course I I
know and understand that his behavior
this season is like not good it's super
unstable the way he talks to Britney is
so sad the way Britney that like has to
defend her husband to her friends like
that sucks um but I think there's like
an underlying thing going on here and
that people think Jax is crazy like he
thinks he's better than everyone he
didn't wanna put sir shirt on and as
much as I thought he was being
unreasonable like I also kind of
understood it because I think what a lot
of people forget is like this show was
built on the back and like the
embarrassment of a lot of people
specifically Jax like there were so many
moments that made this shell like him
sitting with Kristen him then the chunky
knitted sweater like him running a
biggest getting a fight like he really
made this show him I would say him
Kristen and Stassi like really made this
she's like they bled out for the show
and I am sure that it [ __ ] kills him
to walk into Tom Tom like Tom Schwartz
never worked at Sur never really was a
full-time cast member he had one panic
attack when he tried to work that pump
and Lisa Vanderpump kind of handed him
this opportunity on a platter that came
from the show that came from people like
Jax and Kristen and Stassi bleeding out
for the show I am sure and he would
never say this I am sure it [ __ ]
kills him that like they have this
opportunity this business that's gonna
last forever that they like graduated
from the show and they're in charge now
and they are different they were wearing
suits and not Sur shirts in the
photoshoot like I am sure that that
kills Jax like and in his own way he's
on the same level as Tom and Tom
honestly he's he should be above Tom
Schwartz in the hierarchy of Vanderpump
rules but he's not because he doesn't
have a restaurant yeah
honestly I think that's the best point
that you ever made um last night
obviously and just a season Jax's
behavior has been indefensible like he
needs to stop talking about his wedding
but I also feel like a lot of now it's
different like he's it's really a cry
for help like he's trying to tell
everyone that he's not okay and people
just keep saying that's not an excuse
but like he needs help like he isn't
okay I think he's still grieving I think
that he has anger issues I think that he
doesn't know like how to express himself
and I just don't understand why no one
like is jumping to help him when he's
not saying he's not saying I'm sorry
like I won't do it and he's saying I'm
sorry I need help no totally it's like
everyone's ignoring these like major red
flags what he's been doing and saying
the season has been horrible he's making
literally no sense and even Brittany
like she knows that he's going through a
lot like and I feel like the only person
who actually really really understands
that he's having a mental breakdown is
Stassi yeah like she had that
conversation with him and then when
Katie like wanted to block him Stassi
was like no he's literally losing it
like that'll just make it worse I hope
in the reunion we get some sort of
update on this like he was going to
therapy or something because he hasn't
dealt with the loss of his dad I don't
think he's lost dealt with like the loss
of the relationship with his mom like
there's so much there and he won't he
was always like a little like weird and
emotionally unstable but I think all of
these life moments have really pushed
him off a cliff and like nobody it's
like everyone's so fed up with him like
they don't care enough to like how I
helped him yeah and I completely agree
to your point about Tom Tom and Jax is
still bartending at Sur when like he is
responsible for the success of so much
of this along with other people but like
he made he was like that the villain
that just made this show so loveable
where it's like we could all agree oh my
god Jax got the girl pregnant in Vegas
like just he gave so much to the show
and he's gotten really nothing back when
people who have given less to have a
restaurant on the way their name on it
he's gotten stuff out of the show like
he lives this fabulous life he's a star
like whatever all that stuff but in the
confines of the show like they're
celebrating the one-year anniversary Tom
Tom party like he's having to take a
picture with Charlie wearing the same
shirt as Charlie like
no he looked unreasonable but like I
actually understood it like he he's no
one is above anyone but there is a
hierarchy in this whole thing and to me
it's like this show was just built off
the backs of certain people and for him
taps like kowtow to like this photoshoot
that ended up looking like a piece of
[ __ ] like when they deliberately showed
me the picture I'm a concrete what is
that that was really I thought it was
gonna be like another one of those like
sultry like moody pictures that we take
at the beginning of the season we um but
it was like a weird yearbook photo yeah
and I know that like we get a lot of
flack for defending Jax and I'm not
defending Jax like I I agree his
behavior has been in pencil when he say
Thompson I was actually like a woman
like what you should be so lucky to be a
woman like I agree he's out of control
and he's unfiltered but like pardon me
kind of gets what's driving him crazy
like Tom Schwartz just like waltzed into
this opportunity on Jax's back yeah Tom
Schwartz in and I'm sure that's why
Kristen also feels disgruntled krisiun
[ __ ] bled out for this show suck a
dick Diana got fired like James slapping
him in the parking lot like she and Jax
have really become like these villains
but all these people are now like
benefiting from their hard work and
embarrassment
Kristen can't even get on every episode
oh she's barely on the show and now that
that editor went on the podcast and like
said some of the secrets of how they
edit it um she also said that Bobby
Bravo wanted to make Stassi and Beau
look like superheroes and so they needed
to be in every episode just like being
themselves I guess is like some sort of
like pinnacle benchmark um for what like
the cast can aspire to be um and it's
just just to be Kristen and Dom be
treated so differently it just it sucks
but I mean that's the weight like life
is unfair I get that but you can't
expect everyone to be smiling about it
my face is like literally turning around
on me I think so he did I know we just
like had so much defending to do today
ya know - and by the way I can't stress
enough I'm not defending Jax's and I was
like I read they are abhorrent and
indefensible I was fed out last night me
too
like he was gentle and I was just like
you should not be on the show
like you just can't handle it but we
just have to acknowledge like what maybe
is going on behind the scenes I also
think there's stuff I think there's also
stuff going on that we don't know
because they talked her in a way that
makes it seem like they're leaving
something out also even when he was
talking to Lisa Vanderpump he's called
it my show and Lisa Vanderpump to me
like I think Vanderpump rules is more
Jax a show then it is Lisa's like yes of
course Lisa gave him this opportunity
but Lisa has truly added nothing of
value to the show every time she comes
on screen I fast forward it so he's
saying the wrong thing and he doesn't
know how to express how he's feeling but
I totally get part of his frustration I
don't get how he's I don't agree with
how he's taking it out on the people
around him but I get why he's [ __ ]
fed up no like Lisa not belong on his
show was like she should still be the
executive producer I guess all her
restaurants like when she was in the
same room when Danica and scheana 2.0
we're having like the Caddy aesthetics
fight and she's Lisa's they're like
looking at it's like one of these things
is not like the other and it's Lisa
Vanderpump who should be agreed agreed
great that's anything a lot of people
can call this their show and that
doesn't mean they're right or wrong I
think Andy would call it his show I
think Lisa would call it her show I
think Stassi would call it her show I
think Jax could call it his show I think
that Lala has called it her show and
none of them are wrong it is each part
of their shows agree so Matt Vanderpump
no no I wouldn't either but like I'm not
Jax
okay let's dive into your toasters which
is our advice segment if you have
something you want to write and you can
email us dear toasters at gmail.com we
always keep it anonymous and here's our
first one hey Claudia and Jackie SOS I
have a friend who matched with this guy
on tinder while they were both passing
through a city they never actually met
in person but they kept talking and
while quarantine happened so Cinderella
and her prince is cyber romance
continued I thought that he was going to
be that was going to be the extent of it
but homegirl ended up driving 10 hours
to go meet him for the first time
stayed there for a week came home then
bought a one-way ticket to see him just
a few days after she came home she
FaceTime me last night told me she's now
looking to buy a house there and is
interviewing for a couple of jobs me
being the FBI social media friend that I
am
social media snooping I got major player
and fuck-boy vibes from the sky not only
that he's in the military and will only
be in that city for another year and a
half
my friend is known to fall very hard and
do everything and anything for guys
while working even harder to craft up a
story to convince everyone else that the
whole thing is just a coincidence how
the hell do I bring her down to earth
and let her know that she's being
absolutely ridiculous help this is
urgent because she may have already
closed down a house by now
PS you two are the best and I listen to
your show every day xoxo tinder Ella's
helpless friend okay this is interesting
there's some legitimate concerns that
you have and then there are some that I
think is you're just being judgemental
fear of your hopeless romantic of a
friend you think that you thought that
you looked him up I thought you were
gonna see that he has a girlfriend or
he's lying him a second life instead you
got suck boy vibes that while I
understand like you are getting a vibe
that's just not cold hard facts and
that's also you being a little bit
judgmental and wanting to see it go
south I'm not a legitimate concern by
amis right so I think even let's just
operate under the guise that this guy is
a great guy there's nothing wrong with
him there's no reason why she shouldn't
be in a relationship with him but just
her jumping the gun on everything and
not like thinking before she does things
is the cause for concern here buying a
house is kind of crazy in a city that
she's never lived in for a guy who's
leaving in a year and a half maybe she
could rent an apartment try and see it
through like I I I will always take up
for someone who will go the extra mile
to find love and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing I understand
she's been rash in the past has she ever
moved to a whole nother city and bought
a house in the past like is it that sort
of pattern um but I think you should
definitely have a conversation with her
about slowing down but sort of take your
preconceived notions out of it because I
think that you'll lose her like
definitely just operate under the
premise that this is a good relationship
they might even fall in love and lasts
forever but like you have to take things
a little bit slower in order to build a
better foundation right and then at some
point I always harken back to like not
your life not your problems like
sometimes people have to learn for
themselves and like if she's a grown
woman you can do all you can but at the
end of the day you might never get
through it I heard the only way to get
through to her it's like to live through
her mistakes and learn from it and grow
from it and that's what a lot of people
have to go through and sometimes it's
just not on you to fix other people's
problems and I know that you care about
you
friend and I'm sure that that's a
genuine real concern coming from you but
at some point it's not your life says
like get out of it yeah and I just think
the only advice I would give her she was
my friend and I didn't want overstep but
just wanted to raise my concerns is I
would say listen you don't know if
you're gonna like the city you don't
know if the relationships gonna work out
maybe don't buy the house maybe just
look for a short-term rental see how you
even like working there can you get a
job just be a little bit more like
logistically pragmatic about it as
opposed to like condemning her life
choices this is very similar to when
Kerri moved to Paris with Petrovsky and
Miranda said no like how you gonna write
but your job and your friends and she's
like and she had to learn and make her
own mistakes and they come back with her
tail between her legs back to New York
sometimes you got a lot of Carrie be a
Carrie and make their own bad decisions
I totally agree like she absolutely
needed to go to Paris and get humbled
and trip in Dior like that was so
important for her development as a
person ya know she had to fall down the
stairs look with big at the hotel in
order to understand like maybe I
shouldn't just like go off of every
feeling I have totally all right next up
Jackie and Claudia I need your help my
friend Melissa has asked me to set her
up with my other friend Jake they met a
couple times and they've been quite
flirtatious with each other but the
issue is that my friend Melissa has a
history of cheating she's cheated on
every boyfriend she's ever had and she
gets tired of boys very quickly Melissa
knows Jake a signal say go and looking
to get into relationship because we
spoken about it before it came up in a
room conversation when we spoke about
Jake I know that if Melissa and Jake
date that she'll cheat on him too and I
do not want to set the two of them up
but how do I tell Melissa no or what do
I say to her help from a worried toaster
oh that's a terrible predicament to be
and I feel like there's many ways you
could go about this you could like just
drop it and make it seem like Jake was
never interested in Melissa and like
maybe that'll shut her up because she
like be embarrassed that you got
rejected um you could tell Jake be like
hey my friend listen won't set you up
just letting you know her track record
like she's cheated on many guys so just
keep that in the back of your mind but
then that's like you being sleuthy
towards Melissa I just feel like you
should just drop it entirely and like
hope that it goes away yeah hope that it
goes away but maybe like if she keeps
pushing the issue be like listen I love
you I would do a lot for you maybe not
anything but um you are my good friend
he's my good friend I know how you are
with guys are gonna chew him up and spit
him out and that leads me in a weird
position unless you're truly [ __ ]
serious about this like don't ask me
again
yeah I think that up
maybe take out the curse words and stuff
you know of course take everything we
say with a grain of salt but just like
if Jake is a nice guy like you're not
gonna don't do that yeah that's just the
gist when I say things like that it's
just the gist and then you know put some
sugar on it
we're paraphrasing of course of course
but if you need help like crafting an
actual text definitely go get help from
somewhere else because like I can't send
the text for my life no me neither I'm
just like my least like best quality
please best yeah all right they're gonna
final two your toasters dear Claudia and
Jackie how do I begin this tale there's
a man named Charlie or at least that we
think that's what we think his name is
this is a question we are now having to
grapple with our friend has always been
a bragger a teller of stories in college
he told stories about his Butler and
maid and staff while growing up in
Monterrey he openly talks about his
massive trust fund that he will acquire
when he turns 30 he frequently discusses
his large extravagant home in Monterrey
yet he seems to own one sweater two
shirts and live with his aunt and uncle
so he says in a less nice town who look
weirdly just like him he won't show
anyone his driver's license and if he
does he weirdly covers his name rumors
of a different last name have been
mentioned amongst her friends he also
claims to have graduated from
prestigious private high school in the
area however another friend found a
photo online of him in a graduation gown
from a different public high school
across town the lies have built up over
time and our friend group seems
uncomfortable spending time with him
because it seems like everything is a
lie Claudia and Jackie help what should
we do should we confront him and his
lies should we wait until his 30th
birthday in the hope of his life in the
hope his lack of trust fund will topple
his lies should we ignore them and
continue business as usual we've let me
love him either way we just wish he
would be honest signed someone who has
been alive I love catching people in
lies my favorite thing is like meeting
someone new and then figuring out that
they're just the person who lies about
everything and then like knowing that
every time you talk to them and like
catching them in the lies it's my
favorite thing because what the [ __ ] you
lying about freak yeah okay so here's my
two cents it seems like the fact that
you like him makes it a little
challenging but to me I'm getting
like an Adele V grifter vibes and maybe
the lies are harmless for now but
eventually you're gonna wind up in
Morocco with a $20,000 hotel bill put on
your corporate card and it's not gonna
be funny anymore
great analogy great analogy so you need
to stop being friends with this person
and like you'll see them in an episode
of American greed sometime like this is
always how it starts like yeah the
questions like an Adele belied she heard
Hotel in New York like wasn't paid for
she said she heard trust funds coming in
like he will say oh my god it's my 30th
birthday let's go on a trip I got my
trust fund all of a sudden this credit
card doesn't work and it's on your
credit card you do not need friends like
this when I read when I hear these
stories of like these con artists I'm
just like how can these people be so
manipulated so easily and so maybe it's
like no they knew that something was
amiss but they like their friendship so
they let it slide but you know what it's
not gonna be sliding when it's your card
slide and down the ATM slip hopefully
you know how they say like when a when a
kid like kills a cat like they might go
on to kill a human being it's like it's
always the first step there are always
signs when you're such a compulsive liar
like the next thing you do is like you
start stealing you know there's always
this is the beginning and I don't think
you should be there for the end yeah and
I see that you like like this person but
I just I can't imagine like liking
someone who I can't trust you know maybe
like socially hi bye like I'll get a
story from you and it's always
entertaining and funny but in terms of
true friendship like if I can't trust
you we can't be friends agreed this is
it's just it's not good get the [ __ ] out
yeah I'm like obviously this is
entertaining and if this is like gonna
be the next episode of American greed
like I would like to see your
testimonial so maybe always see this
person at arm's length
do not go on a trip with this person do
not go to a restaurant with this person
where you're ordering like bottles of
Dom Perignon just do not find yourselves
in situations with this person where you
might have to pick up the bill right
yeah no it's your corporate card like
get out get out okay thank you guys for
submitting if you want to ever email us
about anything dear toasters at
gmail.com our ears are open and we
always keep it anonymous so no worries
about that yeah this was a really good
episode
so much advice we also did a whole
episode of patron dear toaster so if you
love your toasters like we do you can
head over patreon.com such a morning
toast and there's like a million
questions we gave some great answers we
have three more episodes coming at you
this month Claudia just dropped an
episode with the snitch talking about
Taylor Swift and it's gotten rave
reviews I've been hearing favorite
episode yet that's what I've been
hearing I've been hearing I've been
reading some reviews that people
actually got emotional about it like I
don't know I I saw that too I really did
um but yeah head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast for
all the new content thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up too much time with Ben okay I
can sit you're Public Radio I all right
no cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us and we're
neato silly if I serve you about our
beautiful stunning and smart we are
please pre-order my comedy special
available on iTunes you can swipe up on
my Instagram story or at the link in my
bio on girl with no job thank you guys
so much we will see you tomorrow have a
beautiful and blessed day